nun sind die zahlen veröffentlicht
worden kann ihm das jetzt das genick
brechen weil der durchschnittsamerikaner
der eben wesentlich mehr steuern zahlt
sich jetzt salopp gesagt ein bisschen
verarscht vorkommt also drum löst ohne
mit der wimper
das war eben sehr gut zu beobachten er
hat mit der richtigen tradition dass die
steuererklärung veröffentlicht werden
schlicht gebrochen
es wird ihm in seiner klientel in seiner
stammklientel nicht schaden
diese lege auffassung dass der staat
eine räuberische veranstaltung ist die
den wirklich leisten den amerikanern
etwas wegnimmt und er gilt gerade weil
er als mehrfacher millionär er
behauptete sogar sein milliardär keine
steuern bezahlt hat von seiner klientel
für diese dreistigkeit er bewundert und
insofern rechne ich auch nicht damit
dass im wahlkampf sich an dieser haltung
ich erzähle euch irgendwann mal was ich
an steuern bezahlt habe irgendetwas
ändern wird weil es ihm nützt
das stimmt in der kernklientel die
sowieso zu ihm steht wird das nichts
ändern aber bei denen arbeitern die vor
vier jahren von demokraten zu trump
gegangen sind da kann es was ändern also
im sogenannten rostgürtel pennsylvania
michigan und so wo eben clinton die wahl
verloren hat vor vier jahren die fragen
sich schon warum zahle ich eigentlich
mehr einkommenssteuer als der präsident
und die sind bereit unter umständen auch
sondermann wie beiden zurückzugehen der
seine steuern ganz normal bezahlt heute
nacht erlebt haben war eigentlich ein
dokument wie es darauf hinausläuft oder
drohen zu werden dass diese
amerikanische demokratie massiv
beschädigt wenn nicht zerstört wird
wir haben erlebt ein land wo die beiden
protagonisten ausdruck einer tiefen
gesellschaftlichen spaltung ist und
diese spaltung kommen noch überbrückt
werden kann
biden hat versucht darauf eine antwort
zu finden in dem er ausdrücklich betont
hat ich bin dann präsident aller
amerikaner
wir müssen wieder zusammenkommen er hat
da übrigens in seinen 47 jahren politik
auch eine gewisse vorgeschichte was
bestimmte gesetze angeht die über
parteiübergreifend verabschiedet worden
aber diese debatte offenbart in meinen
augen eine ganz ganz tiefe krise der
amerikanischen demokratie und das muss
uns besorgen
der präsident der vereinigten staaten
sagt über die wahl in ein paar wochen
bis das motto and well
diese wahl wird das wird das all das
wird alles in einem großen katastrophen
er hat sein seinen diesem diesen weißen
rassistischen milizen gesagt leute
haltet euch bereit
er hat auf die frage ob er einen sieg
beiden akzeptiert gesagt schauen wir mal
ich gehe zu gericht aber wir schicken
vor allem unsere anhänger in die
wahllokale
und er hat gesagt das ganze briefwahl
system ohne dass er das belegen kann sei
eine einzige verschwörung gegen ihn das
heißt er erstellt eigentlich wirklich
das funktionieren der amerikanischen
demokratie in frage
und das ist am langen ende ein massives
gewaltpotenzial also eher droht hier
nicht offen mit bürgerkrieg aber er
macht solche anspielungen dass einige
seiner anhänger und da sind wir beim
schimpansen mit maschinengewehren
dass die ihre waffen die er in amerika
verbreitet sind nicht weg stellen
sondern rausholen und glauben sie täten
was gutes für trump kämpfen ich bin
wirklich wirklich hochgradig angespannt
was die zeit nach dem dritten november
angeht das sind ja eigentlich erwarten
wenn joe biden ganz knapp gewinnt eine
verfassungskrise in den vereinigten
staaten müssten damit rechnen ist wenn
es ganz knapp ist am wahlabend selber
wie eine verfassungskrise kriegen und
die briefwahl das wissen wir
die nutzt er den demokraten tendenziell
löst die er den demokraten aber das
dauert lange mit dem auszählen und das
heißt wir werden einen zeit haben in der
wir unter umständen einen präsidenten im
amt haben denn nicht das ergebnis der
wahl akzeptiert und das ist natürlich
eine große verfassungskrise und wie
gesagt da er seine anhänger anstachelt
will ich nicht ausschließen dass es
teilweise zu unruhen kommt mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren